the piracy paradox is a paradox related
to a fashion design may be related to
other things but mostly related to
fashion design the paradox arises from
the following kind of puzzle which is we
usually think of intellectual property
protection copyright for example as a
necessary element for creative
production so riders won't write if they
think there are books are just going to
be copied musicians won't create music
if they think their works are just going
to be stolen and so that's why piracy is
such a problem what's interesting about
fashion design is you see a lot of
creativity in the fashion world and yet
there's no protection for fashion
designs so dress appears in the runway
on the Oscars and the next day two days
later you can buy a cheap version of
that from a company like abs and so the
piracy paradox is looks at this puzzle
and and the idea is that unlike other
industries in which piracy seems to
drive out creativity in fashion it
doesn't drive it out and in fact it
seems to accelerate it and the reason is
that copying of the copying of designs
as it spreads out into the marketplace
makes the original buyer they were the
early adopter of a particular design
want to then move on to something new
all right so fashion is always cycling
and so one way to think about it is it
accelerates the fashion cycle so it's
paradoxically helpful
couple of implications one is that we
probably that our understanding of what
creativity requires which is very
instrumental one in the US legal system
needs to be a little more nuanced and so
when we think of it as a public policy
question to what degree should
government provide these monopolies
rights which is what copyrights and
patents and trademarks are we need to
think about how different industries we
need to be a little more industry
specific so rather than a blanket set of
rules we want to we want to understand
how these industries work and what kinds
of inducements they need so right now
there's a bill before Congress to give
fashion designers a kind of copyright
and that's probably not necessary right
so and there may be other cases in which
it's not necessary I think generally
we're very aggressive about intellectual
property in the u.s. we're quite we're
quite eager to make sure that other
countries protect our intellectual
property I think generally that's been
helpful to us we are the major producer
of movies or a major producer movies
lots of other entertainment industry's
software etc so so intellectual property
is essential to the American economy of
the 21st century and so we've been
understandably aggressive about
protecting it and that i think has been
good for our economy but it's not just
an economic question right so one of the
things that we ought to think about when
we're thinking about how much protection
should be given is what should be in the
public domain what what is a what should
be allowed as fair use how much how long
should the protection be and there i
think there's a fair question to be
asked about whether we have overshot
what is reasonable and so it's very
difficult for example for musicians to
sample other songs more than you know
tiny little snippets because the law has
made it extremely complex and cumbersome
and costly and so many people argue that
we've kind of
gone well beyond what's reasonable and
made the public domain the domain of
things that we can all use in remix and
recreate really inaccessible in a way
that's probably not optimal we've done a
couple of things to get around that one
is in the World Trade Organization which
countries like China are eager to be a
part of and they are in fact remember
we've made an electro party Monteux a
part of that organization so we have a
set of IP rules that every member state
of the WTO has to has to accept and that
linkage between trade and IP has been
very effective we do that in our
bilateral trade agreements as well we go
and we say you want to trade agreement
with us Peru or Colombia or whatever
Australia great but you have to accept a
set of intellectual property rules and
you have to enforce them so so we've
used leverage against these countries
and you know it's not perfect so China
still you can travel in Asia I was in
Vietnam a few years ago and pirated DVDs
are everywhere right so it's not it's
not perfect but we've been cracking down
in a way that we had in the past and I
think that has slowly moved these
countries closer to our preferred
position
it's at an enormous effect on piracy in
that anything that's digital is so music
downloading anything that's digital is
incredibly easy to copy and therefore
the piracy that goes on is rampant so
you know 25 years ago you wanted to copy
a record you had a cassette tape it was
complicated now it's a click and you're
done so technologies had an enormous
effect and that's what has driven a lot
of the concern within the US over
increasing IP protection and making sure
that other countries in a global
marketplace have the same sets of rules
has technology been effective in
fighting it I suppose so but I'm not I
can't say I can think of an example i
think it's primarily been you know been
something that's made the piracy problem
larger on the other hand I think it's
led to certain kinds of innovation in
industries so when the VCR came out
companies are very concerned is going to
be the end of you know the television
industry not the case at all right so it
ended up creating a whole new industry
you know iTunes is now this enormous
company or Norma's enterprise from Apple
that didn't exist so so change brings
opportunity in every economic domain and
I think I p is no different again the
question is how much how do you balance
the incumbent industries against these
these unknown future things that we
can't we can't know or